in addition to the bob Corker fiasco
another republican senator is now at
direct odds with Donald Trump and I'm
talking about Republican Senator Jeff
Flake Jeff Flake has announced he will
not be running for re-election in
Arizona John McCain's counterpart and he
gave this major speech on the Senate
floor yesterday where he basically
crushed almost everything that is the
Donald Trump administration and because
of his opposition to Trump he's retiring
instead of seeking re-election now we'll
talk about whether that's a good
strategy in a second but let's go
through a few of the things that Senator
Jeff Flake said yesterday on the floor
of the Senate starting with we must
never regard as normal the regular and
casual undermining of our democratic
norms and ideals we must never meekly
accept the daily Sundering of our
country the personal attacks the threats
against principles freedoms and
institutions the flagrant disregard for
truth or decency the reckless
provocations most often for the pettiest
and most personal reasons reasons having
nothing whatsoever to do with the
fortunes of the people that we have all
been elected to serve none of these
appalling features of our current
politics should ever be regarded as
normal with respect and humility I must
say that we have fooled ourselves for
long enough that a pivot to governing is
right around the corner a return to
civility and stability right behind it
we know better than that by now we all
know better than that going on to say
the notion that one should stay silent
as the norms and values that keep
America strong are undermined and as the
alliances and agreements that ensure the
stability of the entire world are
routinely threatened by the level of
thought that goes into 140 characters
the notion that one should say and do
nothing in the face of such mercurial
behavior is a historic and I believe
profoundly misguided
I have children and grandchildren to
answer to and so mr. president referring
to the president of the Senate there not
to Donald Trump I will not be complicit
I have decided that I will be better
able to represent the people of Arizona
and to better serve my country and my
conscience by freeing myself from the
political considerations that consume
far too much bandwidth and would cause
me to compromise
far too many principles to that end I am
announcing today that my service in the
Senate will conclude at the end of my
term in early January 2019 in another
part of the speech that I won't put up
on the screen for you flake calls out
those who have unending loyalty blind
loyalty to President Donald Trump so
good for flake right it's all fine and
good good speech powerful and everything
that Jeff Flake said is correct but if
you oppose Trump why take yourself out
making it easier for a Trump backed
puppet to win in the election that will
be held to replace you I would argue if
you're trying to help the country that
is the worst possible thing to do
because you're potentially enabling a
trump astac to take your place and by
the way flake said he'd no longer be
complicit with Trump's nonsense flake
voted with Trump pence just last night
to give predatory banks more power over
consumers after giving this major speech
he voted and is complicit in the
disasters that Trump Pence are bringing
to the United States so flake is not
some liberal hero he's a hardcore
Republican all he's done here is
recognized that Trump is out of his mind
which everyone should do right flake is
no hero merely for noticing the obvious
and the wind from Jeff Flake speech
combined with bob Corker yesterday
saying that Donald Trump needs adult day
care whatever phrase he used is that
we're seeing Republicans say enough
enough ridiculing of gold star families
enough add homonyms against anyone who
dares to question anything that Donald
Trump says or does that's the possible
win it's not that we have a new
progressive hero in Jeff Flake or bob
Corker we all need to be saying no more
this is the United States and we don't
want this but in the end it's American
politics right Jeff Flake wrote an op-ed
to coincide with this speech in The
Washington Post and he said for the next
14 months I am relieved of the
strictures of politics and I will be
guided only by the dictates of
conscience the fact that he had to point
out now that I'm quitting and no longer
running for
re-election I am going to be guided by
my conscience rather than my politics
that's the problem with American
politics and it's gone over the head of
a lot of people who are just focusing on
the Senate speech he should have been
following his morals and his conscience
his entire career right not just the 14
months until he's done in the Senate but
the growing bigger picture is this civil
war within the Republican Party a civil
war by Republicans by more and more
Republicans against a president who was
never really a Republican until he
figured out that he could bamboozle
Republican voters into voting for him
flake and bob Corker have gone off on
Trump and Trump is fighting back he's
totally triggered he's he as triggered
as he has ever been tweeting this
morning the reason flake and corker
dropped out of the Senate race is very
simple they had zero chance of being
elected now act so hurt and wounded
that's not true by the way and Donald
Trump also tweeting Jeff Flake with an
18% approval rating in Arizona said a
lot of my colleagues have spoken out
really they just gave me a standing
ovation Trump cannot help himself
and right-wing media is trying to cover
this up they're trying to cover up the
civil war
I actually tuned in to Fox News for a
few minutes while the flake speech was
happening yesterday they were talking
about that bogus Hillary Clinton uranium
non-story
but what civil war no absolutely nothing
is going on and the real headline the
red alert for Republicans should be hey
our voters are so easily manipulated
that a lifelong greedy conman with no
values and no valuable ideas whatsoever
tricked our electorate defeated 16 other
candidates in the Republican primary and
is now President of the United States if
I'm in the Republican Party I'm worried
that their electorate was so easily
tricked by this conman buffoon
so - Jeff Flake I disagree with Jeff
Flake on fiscal policy I disagree with
Jeff Flake on economic policy I disagree
with Jeff Flake about almost everything
but he's right that the
values that the United States is
supposed to embody are not the values
that Donald Trump is espousing and I
think it's a good thing that he spoke
out he now faces the ultimate punishment
which is the ire of Donald Trump and his
blindly loyal dogmatic followers they
now see flake as the problem when the
reality is that it is they who are the
problem
we'll see what ultimately happens in
Arizona with the election to replace
Jeff Flake the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad